can't hear when he's reading. You wait
until he pauses. If he gives you enough
time, you give him. If not, he
continues. But if you feel that he's
kind of he's kind of asking you,
then the person directly behind him with
a nice clear voice so that he can hear.
Very good.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in.
We have just completed the fifth
chapter which is the chapter of
vigilance of Allah's observation.
We're getting now into the sixth chapter
which is the chapter of
if we were to look at from a bird's eye
view how is it comprised
is comprised of 19 books.
Okay, 19 books and an extensive
introduction of general things, telqua,
honesty, vigilance,
etc. Honoring the guest, what have you.
So, we have 19 books and then we have
this extensive
almost just just shy of a hundred or
a little less chapters. we have
yes 83 chapters. So 83 chapters
followed by
19 books each book on a particular
topic. For instance, the book of
manners, the book of etiquets, the book
of traveling, the book of virtues,
the book of prohibitions, right?
the book of miscellaneous
things whatever didn't fit in the first
chapters or 19 books is mentioned at the
end. The beautiful thing about
it's almost just just a little shy of
2,000 narrations. There is some slight
repetition. However, if a person were to
read,
become dedicated to
and study it, study it to where it's as
if the person has memorized it. They
haven't memorized it, but it's as if it
is memorized. They are very familiar
with it. If they needed to look
something up, they can recall it. that
kind of familiarity then this person has
made himself familiar
with a huge chunk of the
prophet's sunnah. As a matter of fact,
we might even dare say most of the
essential core narrations and sunnah of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
if we were to look at Bkari and
Muslim take them together together
without repetition
right without repetition we're going to
have just shy of 30ome
narrations
30ome hundred narration 3,000 and some
narrations without repetition
is going to mention a big majority of
that because most of is comprised from
Bkari Muslim. So this book is a
milestone. It is an essential book of
reading for every Muslim. Every Muslim.
This is the book that a person should
become familiar with. If a person were
to say, "What should I read? What should
I recite? if I'm reading the Quran
every day, I want to become more
familiar with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam with his sunnah. We say the 40
narrations of a noi. We start with those
because those are the principles of all
of the sunnah. And then we follow that
up with
and we understand
through the lens of the 40 narrations.
Meaning anything that is generalized in
we take it back to the specificity of
those 40 narrations. Those are the
principles of the prophet sunnah of much
of the principles of Islam in general,
right? including the Quran. If we read
the Quran, we understand it through the
lens of
fat through the lens of the 40
narrations. When you're reading a book
of hadith like
what are you reading? You're reading a
of the Quran. That's what it is. You are
reading the
implementation and understanding of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam of the
Quran.
and any additions that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala found fit. The sixth chapter
now is the chapter of
the chapter of a tawa.
If what if we were to say what would you
translate tawa to a tawa? What do you
guys think?
You say translate what does a tawa mean?
What would you translate it as?
consciousness of Allah. Well, we got
that first in, didn't we? We just we
just finished that chapter. What What do
you understand a ta to be?
[Arabic recitation]
Okay. So if we say if we say for
instance
Allah says what does that translate to?
[Arabic recitation]
fear. If you read in some
it will say fear. Right
now this is an important point.
Fear
is not necessarily tawa. However, fear
is the driving force behind tawa.
Okay. If I said for instance, if I
[Arabic recitation]
Well, you can't keep interrupting
with half things. So, if we were to say
a car for instance, we mention
I can refer to the car by some of its
most critical components, right? So, I
can call a car wheels, right? What about
if I say we need some speed?
Speed,
right? I need something fast. I need I
need to get some, you know, some
speed going. This can also be a
reference to the car. It's not part of
the car, is it? It's not part of it.
However, it is the it is the
essential
attribute of the car. It is the driving
force behind the car. Its existence, its
presence, all of that. That is why we
have cars. That's why we manufacture
them. That is why they that is the
propelling force.
The same thing here with tawa and fear.
When we say tawa
means fear of Allah, not really. Fear is
what makes a person exhibit tawa.
It's the thing that makes a person have
tawa. We say what is the essential
driving force behind a person
observing tawa? It is fear of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala. But when we look
into the language of the word tawa, we
see that it shares a common etmology and
root word with
from something violent or something that
is harmful. We call this a it can be
something that is steel or iron.
It could be something that is a
piece of clothing. It is a
right. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that
[Silence]
So
Allah mentions this word as a verb and
he says that he has provided for us
knowledge to be able to design clothing
and fashion clothing for ourselves that
will protect us from the sun that will
protect us from the violence of others,
right? Armor. So we see that the word
tawa is to
use take something as a shield. Now when
we look at the Quran, we see that Allah
uses this verb with respect to himself.
He uses this word with respect to the
hellfire,
right?
What does this mean? This means that we
are taking a shield. We are shielding
ourselves from the anger of Allah, from
the hellfire, from the punishment of
Allah. So when Allah says, he's
essentially saying, shield yourselves
from Allah's anger. When he says,
he's saying, "Shield yourselves from the
fire." When he says,
"Shield yourselves and your family from
a fire, blazing fire."
So, a tawa is a shield. It's a shield,
right? And when he uses it as an as an
adjective,
a description, he refers to the people
of Eman as
what does that mean? They are the people
who have managed to successfully shield
themselves from the punishment of Allah.
That's a mut. Who is a mut? the one who
has managed to accomplish shielding
himself from the anger and the
punishment of Allah from the hellfire.
Now here's the question. Who is the only
person that can protect you from Allah?
[Arabic recitation]
protect you from Allah. Correct? Listen
to this narration. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam used to
make the dua. Used to make this dua and
he used to say,
"Oh Allah, I seek refuge in your
pleasure from your anger.
And I seek refuge in your pardon from
your justice.
Mink
and I seek refuge in you from you.
There is no protection nor escape from
you except with you.
Allah says
This is this is the essence of
Allah says so run to Allah
flee to Allah. He says commenting on
this verse
he says this means flee from Allah to
Allah.
The only one that can protect you from
Allah is Allah. This is where the Muslim
and the
this is where they clash essentially
because the mushri say
that they worship other than Allah to
protect them from Allah. meaning that
they will intercede on their behalf.
What did the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam say to his daughter
Fatima or announced in general? He said,
he said, "Oh, Fatima, daughter of
Muhammad, ask me of my possessions and
I'll give them to you. Anything you
want, but I cannot save you from Allah."
What did the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam say to his dying uncle?
He saidill
he said sayahill
and I will use this statement that you
make as an argument for you before
Allah. So what does this mean? This
means that no one can save you from
Allah except for Allah. Now, how do we
go about obtaining Allah's
salvation?
we understand now that the only one
that can save you from Allah is Allah.
So now, how do I get Allah to save me
from himself? What's the answer?
very good is to obey a law.
He said worship and righteous deeds that
boils down to obedience, right? So here
is the definition of a tawa.
Remember this, memorize this. These are
not just fancy words. I could sit up
here every day and tell you stories and
make you feel real nice and feel
butterflies in your stomach and in your
tummy every time you sit down. I could
entertain you. I could. Yeah. And then
we could do this for 20 years and
nothing will change in your life.
Or we could start learning what our
Allah's words mean. When I'm teaching
you these things, it's not for my
benefit. I mean, I benefit in the sense
that I hope Allah accepts it as a form
of worship, but I know these things. I
could keep them to myself.
Do you not think that the style of
teaching that I have,
it makes a lot of people it it some
people don't sit around for it, right?
They leave. Why? Because it's not very
entertaining. And you got to you got to
you have to put in an effort to learn
something. I'm teaching you
how to free yourselves
from servitude to other human beings.
I want you to learn so that you don't
need other people to tell you what Allah
said. I want you to understand what
Allah said.
And that is only going to happen if we
put in the hard work. Here is the
definition of awa as posited by the
scholars of Islam. They tell us
for
[Silence]
he is
heavy.
for
here.
[Silence]
Right?
So for instance, this is the or this is
the definition of a tawa. very important
word for us to understand the definition
of it's all over the Quran. It's all
over the Sunnah.
What is a tawa?
The scholars tell us a tawa is defined
as
shielding yourself
from the punishment of Allah
by fulfilling his commandments and
abstaining from his prohibitions.
That is a tawa.
A tawa
is obtaining a shield. Shielding
yourself from the punishment of Allah,
from the anger of Allah, from the wrath
of Allah. Shielding yourself
from the punishment of Allah
by fulfilling his obligations
and refraining from his prohibitions.
Right? Who are the of Allah? What make
who is a
we hear this a lot, right? The is some
kind of mystical thing.
Tell me loud.
It's okay. Say it. Say whatever you
remember.
Put a big smile on my face. Now you're
thinking correctly. And that is what is
a wii? We have a verse from the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
[Silence]
indeed the true saints,
the true chosen
with Allah, the true close alliance of
Allah. No fear upon them and no grief or
sadness will overtake them in the end.
Who are they? The ones who believe and
observe the tawa of Allah.
What is the tawa of Allah? It is say it
back to me quickly and I'll let you go.
What is a tawa? Define it.
shielding yourself from the punishment
of Allah by
observing his obligations and abstaining
from his prohibition. Memorize it.
Go on the video, the Facebook, review
it. Right? If you really want to benefit
from these classes every day, review the
video
after you leave here on your drive on
whatever, review it. Review it every
day, twice, three times. Review it till
you've memorized or committed to memory
not only the meanings but the language
of the scholars because that's
important. A lot of times people know
something but they're unable to
communicate it in the language of the
scholars.
We will end with that.
[Arabic recitation]